right now we've got one of three couples
that were left standing after their
experience and love is blind which all
of us I'm sure have now been watched by
now I'm so joining me is Damian and Gigi
oh my gosh guys it's so great to see
y'all we really loved our time on
speaking of we are all in this time of
quarantine right now where are you all
spending your time together yes so we we
both have a good balanced look at our
own places which is really cool so
during the day a lot of times Litro stay
here in her office I have an office in
my place we weren't sort of separately
so we can stay on track unless we're
doing a project together and then we'll
meet up during the day and you know
we'll try to go for like a little walk
around her neighborhood or something you
know that's not very populated
yeah she'll make us dinner or well but
make something to bring it over or do
movie nights so we still like spend a
lot of time together but when we're
doing work stuff we're just trying to
split it that way we don't distract each
other it's almost like been a really
good balance like I think now I was like
okay I want you to spend every single
day with me and my place and never go
back to your house like public little
logs as the old saying goes absence
makes the heart grow fonder right I
think we're all feeling that for sure
right now with so many of our family
members and our friends that were not
being that we're not able to spend time
with right now there's no sleeping other
night and stuff but we still we still
have our times I mean maybe wants to
pricier the week result our own places
but we still do like spend as much time
together as we can is this kind of like
remind you guys is it a throwback to
love his blinds like filming the
episodes for the
show participating in this experiment
because you guys were sequestered for
the sake of the show you were in this
kind of isolation mode already you feel
like you're like whoa whoa whoa are we
going back to the five leaves uh you
know have you ever played read The
Hunger Games
watch yes you know ii know like don't
take me back it kind of feels like that
but in a much more like relaxed way
where I didn't have my yes a for me so I
get a lot of people like how you holding
up your quarantine I've said I've
already done this so yeah like she said
last time we didn't have cell phones we
didn't have TV we did have radio it was
just strictly you know maybe like you
know we had a journal we could write in
so which was sort of cool I miss things
about the pod and the show that were
really like there's heartfelt moments
that allowed me to like focus on myself
and I'm growing you know with GE in
there um but out here it's not I'm not
happy about the situation but it's not
been like the worst I yeah I am ready no
open a tab again now I never thought I'd
be excited to say that yeah but I mean I
think we've done things to past 14 for
sure I mean we've been redoing our
places you know through quarantine
birthday party and did a bunch of stuff
for her I know happy birthday by the way
happy belated well I mean it's it's
weird because you've got like this you
know it's bittersweet kind of feeling
we're obviously you guys could spend it
with the two of you together
everything and I'm sure you wanted to
include other people in the mix and I've
got my birthday coming up on Saturday so
it's like what you can do you know if
it's any consolation I just I don't know
maybe because I knew it was my birthday
I woke up really happy that day and it's
just I guess it got to the point where
it's like okay I know I'm not gonna see
my family but I'm still gonna make the
best out of it it's still my birthday
like what can I do that's different and
I just like I just lounge tray table
drinking champagne and then he just made
it super special because he like
surprised needs throughout the day they
like a little surprise birthday party at
his place too like a good so it was like
all these little things that were not
expected I mean it was definitely a
quarantine birthday that's all I needed
I was really happy it was good now that
we're in a sense of self isolation mode
and have been in for several weeks now
you know you're with your significant
other
and you start noticing things that you
just never noticed
or maybe you kind of noticed it and
they've been hiding so have there been
any of those circumstances where you're
like oh my pet peeves or like I pet
peeves towards my significant other are
really shopping right now like you just
gotta stop with this or that so have you
guys experienced the whole petty thing
in quarantine oh I think it's anything
new I mean I think it's always been like
little things that we just it's always
there and we like when is it gonna
happen and yeah what is it gonna happen
and either you deal with it or you just
you go back to your place for a few
hours we're doing this later I mean
really crazy allergies and so right now
it's pollen season here in Georgia and
like I like to keep my door open and all
this stuff and he does this thing where
he clears his throat right and I've
always heard it for
and now it's all the time and it sucks
cause it hurts never thought but I'm
like I can't right now I gotta go over
here now that genius let you know Jamie
and what is kind of a little bit
aggravating and pet peeve ish for her
what is your biggest pet peeve about G
during this quarantine time famous thing
it's always been it's you know trying to
get attention from her like is a super
hard like you got like time when I'm
with her for her to like listen if I
tell her something it's like five times
you know that's my business
communication I'm just naturally here's
the ears were she asked me a question
something important I answered and she's
like huh and then she does it again I'm
like I'm sorry and I'm like and I'm like
boy like my biggest frustrations just
because I'm always like that
hey deal with the no way so it's we're
still good though it's not like it ruins
our day or on your Instagram recently
you posted a video that you had
submitted to survivor yes and you were
like this Fitness you know in the gym
almost like crossfit style doing all
these crazy you know tricks and things
like that would you guys ever entertain
doing another reality show together yeah
yeah we'd love to do an adventure I feel
like The Amazing Race I would definitely
do survivor that audition tape was when
I was 21 and my little sister was 7 at
this time and actually helped me video
all those scenes yeah she's super
tech-savvy but yeah be partners in this
correct I think we go hiking all the
time
a lot about like wilderness survival
like all this stuff so I kind of just
see it it's like why not I kind of I go
super hard
anything I can there is a reality check
coming out on Netflix - hot - you know
couples being isolated at a resort and
they cannot have intimate relations with
each other for a month so what kind of
tips tricks advice would you give these
couples that are going into another
reality show where can we sign up for
this set up hey we've done it before I
think we've actually pretty good of that
all we just have to get in the fight
once every two days would be good lose a
dollar you're single I feel like that
would be a little bit easier because you
have no connection easier but you know
like that looks like I wanted to like
jump you up I did jump you when I saw
you first though you saw a run back to
the bottom then came back she's had to
think about it she's like yeah so what
advice would you give them when it comes
to thank because clearly clearly they're
gonna be experiencing it on a completely
different level I'd say even for me
Angie I mean it's it's the kind of
person you are right some people can
take it in a bad way some people take it
in a positive light it can become very
overwhelming but if you're very genuine
you're very humble I think it comes
easier to me like what I want to see
people I've been attacked by 600 people
in a matter of 2 3 hours and I want to
tag you know just flaunted highly
approached yet and I don't turn anybody
away my case so nice to meet you like
thank you so much for watching because
and then the day wherever you end up
after a show like love is blind or the
show coming out Netflix you are there
because of the people believe in you in
the world and wanting to watch your
story and wanting to see how you
progress so the more you're interactive
with your fans and the people that
really love you for who you are
and I think it just comes easier yeah
because you enjoy it more you but you
got to keep the negative away that's why
they says you're gonna get so much I
haven't logged into Twitter in a month
yeah because I don't care to see the
negative stuff and when I do see it if I
see a negative comment I delete it
that's rule number one
yeah haters just honestly the only
opinion that should matter your family
that's what you should focus on because
you can't please everybody
you just can't so but I think that in
general its it can be something that
Canada put a lot of things into
perspective for you like right now
whenever I do go to like the grocery
store or to my mailbox and like someone
recognizes me it's right it's like
really it's exciting it's exciting for
example and it's like what like you're
here like I'm like yeah like we're gonna
be fine and I can kind of like all
person to constellation because when
they see me it's like this like surprise
treat like I'm in isolation but I just
you know met someone that we really like
on TV so I think just you know offering
just kind of like a relief and that
always having boundaries always have
values within yourself people want to
know everything about you but just know
what you wanna keep to yourself share
whatever you want the world and just be
nice to people like you said we're
always here well you guys heard about
season 2 love is blind when we could see
it like burn the rumblings behind the
state yeah I don't know when they're
gonna start I just know that season 2
and they're casting doubt and they're
casting so season two and three got
announced so well if you hear any scoop
you know
spill the tea over here we love know
bring it on over here
[Music]